never be a ranger
huh
what
huh
503 to know vector shall damage sister
board appears to be intact I mustn't if
you Ally row City dad they are in danger
whoa hey who's in danger and army is
coming I must warn them go hang on slow
down you've been in a crash what do you
say we get you back to my garage I'll
run a diagnostic and have you fixed up
in no time thank you I appreciate the
assistance it's no problem so what do I
call you I suppose my proper designation
is warbot detect be 54 297 maybe I'll
just call you Clank my name is ratchet
up and down yes there you go you're a
natural million thoughts raced her
Rockets head hoodie repair this
diminutive war box would it be too teeny
to the adventure he craved did he leave
the proto engine on in the garage the
answer to all these questions was yes
all right hang on I'll get us back to
the garage
large gap where child's play to Rogers
all he would need to get across is a
trusty slingshot and a little bravado
impressive shooting nice work
blarg what are they doing here I have
information in my data banks that pose
the threat to chairman drek he must have
tracked my position to your planet so he
could get it back an army of large was
now scouring the planet in search of
slag tomorrow notoriously blue the race
who just happened to have played a major
role in the extinction of the long
backswing arim listen to me I want you
to lock the garage doors and then head
down into the shelter I'll be there as
soon as I can it was in a bad way her
confused and alone he scoured the kizzle
plateau for signs of nano text
water dropship
to be exact also known as the dropship
of dead
ratchet
given it we gotta look for some defect
yeah the boys are all over crystallized
crimped are you okay
just don't I crim I got this
incoming drop ship detected
weapons in parts everywhere and you
clean it up last week fun with
singularities and other cataclysmic
events that's really more for education
demek all right coast is clear can you
open up just exploring sorry about that
Graham listen get my tools ready I just
found something in the desert I need to
look at interesting what kind of factory
is this this now this is just garage
lived here since I was a kid come on
let's get you fixed up once they were
safe Clank explained Rex plan to attack
the Hall of Heroes with the Galactic
Rangers out of the equation ratchet knew
he had to help even though neither he
nor Clank had the upper body strength
necessary for a hero work I can totally
help oh I could not ask a civilian to
get involved in something so dangerous
no I'm not just a civilian the Rangers
are actually my friends why do you think
i have so many pictures of them but why
are you not in any of them well someone
had to take the picture right I mean
come on are you gonna have a ship
it disassembles so it can infiltrate
enemy strongholds so what do you say
this is the story of alum backs named
ratchet and his robot friend Clank and
the muscular irresistibly handsome hero
who have them saved the galaxy
Benson